imagine that you are working on
tributed system so your application runs
on multiple machines you
bubbly have multiple microservices
multiple components there is some
database file storage service bascule
whatever else you can imagine a lot of
these things running in parallel so then
the user comes in hits some load
balancer then the request is routed to
some web server and the workflow starts
so probably sounds fin hits database
file storage etc etc multiple components
are in play and then because all of
these is distributed something runs in
London here in UK some other machine
runs in Seattle some other machine in
talk here Japan so generally those
things are all around the globe
so things they do fail this is typical
in distributed systems so now your user
gets an error message telling that hey
something went wrong etc and user comes
to your support saying hey please fix
this this is some idea of the workflow
etc go and figure out what happened so
now comes the question how do we
structure our locks or how do we lock
information in the distributed system so
we can figure out what exactly happened
what happened not necessarily not only
like in which components but also in
which order so how the things were
executed especially that we are talking
distributed systems here they are very
long that will cause there are things
running on the west and east side of the
globe there are things running in
parallel and running serially at the
same time so during this talk we'll try
to figure out how to log information in
the system so that later we can extract
the D order of this information so we
can recapture the order of how the
operations how they're all the steps
were executed one after another so
that's the point and during this talk
we'll figure out how to add some
ordering to the head chaotic world of
distributed services before we move on
few words about me I used to be a dotnet
developer now I'm I'm a machine learning
Big Data guy at Amazon Seattle
mosa blogger public speaker feel free to
drop me a line on Twitter email whatever
works for you at the end of this talk
those a QR code pointing you data to the
slide deck so you can download this deck
and walk it through on your own time
also like last year I released this book
called dope net internals cookbook which
explains a lot of things which are
running under the hood and open
how my modern management is structured
motive readying shame how interrupts
interrupts with C++ work etc so if you
are interested in these things feel free
to take a look it's supposed it's meant
to be second so it's like a series of
questions and answers with links
pointing to various sources so it's just
like the beginning of the journey okay
let's move on
so agenda for this talk like we started
with stating the problem okay there is
some logging we would like to recapture
the order of steps in our system so the
most obvious solution we probably which
probably comes to our mind is why not
just lock the timestamp when we are
doing any logging so logger that log
provide a timestamp provide enough that
details what's going on and the thing is
timestamp and wall clock in general
doesn't work in distributed systems and
it's proven that it won't work so in the
first part of this talk I'll try to show
you what problems we may face face when
we are working with time in distributed
systems and by time I mean here mostly
wall clock like that time saying it's 2
p.m. in London for instance so then
we'll figure out after seeing that
clocks they do not work for us we'll
figure out what we can use instead of
using wall clocks so we will see how to
avoid clocks in computer science and
then we'll see some real implementation
showing you how to make this things
simple and yet working correctly
ultimately we'll just go beyond the time
and we'll focus on some broader computer
science problems like how to solve
consensus or how to introduce like total
on during ordering in our system which
is not the main point of our problem we
are solving but still something we can
generalize later so what is time like
the obvious solution for ordering the
logs is we extract all the logs from all
the machines and we sort them by the
time stone yeah the only problem with
time is apart from like some physical
definition that is like transitions of
cesium these many transitions in each
second is that there is no global time
every single machine every single clock
every single watch on your wrist is
basically showing different time and
while for us human is not a problem when
it differs by a second or even
by minute four computers it gets really
serious because all the operations we
are running in our systems they are
pretty fast operation can execute in
like nanoseconds so if our clocks they
differ by a second it's way too long for
the operating system and for the
machines to figure out what is going on
and also because we are using clocks and
we need super high precision clocks tend
to increase their error rate as well and
when we increase the precision so we
when we would like to have like
nanosecond precision for our watches
like the error rate so the time when
clocks go out of sync is increasing
significantly I mean it's much faster it
can be after a few seconds obviously
clocks can differ not only because of
their like problematic construction but
also because the operating system or the
Machine you are working on is actually
moving this is like a lot of relativity
by Einstein telling us that hey the
higher we are above the earth and the
faster we move like the time changes so
basically these are things which we need
to take into account when we are
implementing distributed systems or
things like which are working in the
space or working on a plane so using a
time is not necessarily a super simple
in the in the scenario would like to
consider but also when it comes to the
time there is yet another issue which
which is called a time zone and whenever
someone mentions a time zone we tend to
think about whole number of hours
counted from UTC so we say the time zone
is UTC +2 for instance or UTC -6
unfortunately that's not the answer
because we do have a thing called
daylight saving time and in daylight
saving time we basically change our
clocks we move them like forward by one
hour on move them back by one hour this
is what we typically do and we may think
that DST daylight saving time is simple
because hey it happens every single year
and we generally no more or less know
when it's happening
the problem with DST is around the globe
it happens on different time like most
of the European countries they change
their time like end of
and they move forward one hour starting
at 2:00 a.m. so they moved to 3:00 a.m.
and they are good but it's not always
the case for instance United States they
change the time for DST like a week
earlier or week later than the Europe
does also some countries they introduce
DST at midnight or five minutes after
the midnight not to mention that the
countries they change their regulations
for instance European Union now passed a
law that each country can basically
decide hey are you staying on DST or not
and if you are not staying on DST you
can choose whether it's winter time or
summer time so these things they do
change they are not carved in stone and
unfortunately it's very hard to reason
about the time like when we are
considering things which are happening
in the future or in the past because if
we are imagine a very simple ticketing
system for instance you would like to
book a flight which will depart at 8:00
a.m. how far from now how do you show it
in your calendar for the user because if
you show it at 8:00 a.m. then how far
you're from now probably the user will
be in different time zone will be in DST
or summer time or whatever else so then
it may be showing at 9:00 a.m. instead
of 8:00 a.m. and this is pretty serious
bug however if you show it currently at
7:00 a.m. or 9 a.m. depending on which
side of DST we are going on then the
user may come in and tell you hey this
thing is showing me incorrect time
because I booked the flight at 8:00 a.m.
departing at 8:00 a.m. so generally
these things are not simple when we
consider them globally across the globe
and also timezone or like the whole
number of hours when we typically think
about timezone this is not obviously the
same around the globe there are
countries even now which differ by like
30 minutes or 45 minutes but if you take
a look at some historical data it's
getting even more interesting I'm from
Poland so if we take a look at Europe
were so time and get some very old date
like end of 1899 and we check hey what
was the local time at 7:20 if we start
converting this to Europe were so time
getting this very old date we actually
end up with something which is basically
7:44 why is that because at that time
were so was using time zone plus one
hour and 24 minutes and these things
they unfortunately changed a lot so then
we were introducing winter time and
summertime between 1957 1964 then we
dropped summer time then we restore to
summer time now European Union passed
this law so we may drop the summer time
again this week's change
not to mention that right now we move to
summer time like end of March but we
also did it like in June 12 30 or 40
years ago so these things are getting
very very tricky when we start
considering just a very simple term like
time also when we consider what is the
time zone of various countries around
the globe it's not always the case that
the bigger country the more time zones
because for instance US has multiple
time zones but if we take a look at
China China runs only in one time zone
it's also getting even different for
instance in Russia there are multiple
time zones but once you step through the
door to your train station you change
the time zone because all trains they
run using one time zone only across the
whole Russia so these things are pretty
tricky and they change significantly so
any like relying on time zones around
the globe may be super hard for you the
things with DST just to wrap up this
topic they are even interesting because
for instance take United States United
States they do have summer time and
winter time unless you are in Arizona
which is like here's south west of us
Arizona doesn't follow summer time
unless you are another tribe in Arizona
they do follow summer time so it's not
only sufficient to tell you hey where
you live it's all you also need to say
hey who you are so generally time zone
is a region of the globe which is
observing the same time so it's super
hard for computers to follow correctly
also there are two terms UTC and GMT we
tend to use them like interchangeably
UTC and GMT that's the same
unfortunately they are completely
different UTC is based on atomic clock
and it's supposed to approximate the GMT
time this approximation
is allowed to differ by up to 0.9 of a
second so 900 milliseconds that's why
the UTC needs to introduce a thing
called leap second so it's like one
second which is sometimes added can be
also removed but this never happened but
is allowed by the standard to adjust the
UTC to the GMT GMT is tied to the
rotation of the earth divide your froat
eights and goes around the Sun so that's
why because you probably know that like
one year is not exactly 365 days it's
also like this six hours and something
else so these things go out of sync
pretty often and when it comes to leap
second assuming you still would like to
rely on a time the leap second which
seems seemingly easy so like it's one
second introduced to your clock can for
instance take down half of the world and
this actually happens something like
eight years ago there was a bug in Linux
kernel so the task scheduler was going
completely crazy and you had a very big
CPU spikes for like few minutes just
because this one second was introduced
and my sequel was going completely down
you had to reboot your machine or reboot
the service to get it working so
generally this is this already happened
and we may safely assume it will happen
again however this time we should be a
little more prepared because instead of
introducing this one second what we do
now is called time smearing time
smearing is we take this one second and
we basically make all the seconds of a
minute slightly longer so it's not that
we have 61 seconds in a minute when we
introduce leap second we have 60 seconds
but each second is lasting slightly
longer than 1,000 milliseconds but
things get even like harder assuming
that we would like to synchronize these
clocks somehow so I told you that time
zone changes and for instance each
country can decide hey we are dropping
time zone we are dropping DST we are
moving to different time zone so how do
our computers know what is going on and
this thing is called TZ or time zone
database it's distributed by a
organization called Ayana internet
assigned numbers Authority
just publishing multiple times a year a
database cheesy info which tells you
exactly hey this place has this time
zone so this is the DST etc etc
obviously there is some now it's RFC and
there is some nice updating this package
through you're probably able to get or
whatever else raise your hand if you
were aware of this package okay I can
see few hands that's great for all of
you who you were not aware that this
package exists well things are getting
even more interesting because obviously
it couldn't be that there is one package
there is a thing called cldr which is in
Microsoft Word and an apple world which
is also emitted periodically
periodically and also tells you not only
the time zone but also the locales so
for instance if you have seen and us or
NGB languages this is basically stored
in this database as well the problem
with cldr and TC info is that they are
out of sync they are not synchronized
they use completely different names so
generally if you do have Windows machine
and Linux machine like good luck with
synchronizing the clocks however the
thing is okay there is a TC database
which is distributed and we do have time
which we can store in local time or UTC
time and now when we ask a question hey
star my time in local or UTC you go to
stack overflow Stack Overflow tells you
go with UTC there will be no problem
ever ok so let's see how it works and
UTC is not a silver bullet because
things they do change European Union
passed this law so let's see what may
happen in your applications like soon in
two years so we would like to organize
some event on September in 22 at a 9
a.m. in Amsterdam currently the time
zone or the time offset from UTC for
Amsterdam on September 4 2022 is
expected to be plus 2 hours so what we
can do we can take the time store it as
UTC and Stack Overflow said hey it's
going to work so let's see so we take
the time it's 9:00 a.m. we subtract two
hours to get the UTC time so we have 7
a.m. that's what we store in our
database forever but then Amsterdam or
the Netherlands they decide hey we are
not going to use the est anymore
we'll just stick to some Atul wintertime
so after some time which we don't know
yet when they are going to pass
regulations and make the decision
whether it's wintertime or summertime or
whatever else like they do make this
difference and then they are expected to
be plus one on that September 4th 2022
so on September 4th we go to database we
get the UTC time which is 7:00 a.m. we
check the timezone try this plus one we
move one hour forward and we end up with
8:00 a.m. so this thing is now broken
if you ever store your time stamps for
events in database and never ever update
them raise your hand yep so you may go
then check out what's going to happen in
European Union eight years okay so
that's not the solution of you see with
UTC can we do better obviously we could
do better we can store as UTC but we
need to update the time so there is this
TZ info database or cidr which is
distributed periodically whenever we get
a new version of TZ info we get the UTC
time we calculate block out time using
old TZ version then we calculate UTC
time using new TZ version and we update
the value in database plus well this
solution works unfortunately this is
pretty hard because we need to store not
only the current is info but also the
old one and not only we need to store
the UTC time but also the version of the
scene for which we used to store the
time so these things are getting
slightly harder the other solution which
we could use is basically store this as
a local time but not necessarily as like
date time or timestamp or whatever type
you are using in your language but as
something strictly saying hey event is
at 9:00 a.m. like a string or whatever
else you can imagine you do keep this
and then you don't care whether TZ info
was updated in the meantime or not you
just grab this thing and you recalculate
this accordingly whenever user asks you
for the answer hey when this thing is
going to happen and this is actually the
source of true for the event because the
organizer of the event came to your
system and said hey I'd like it to be at
I am NOT at UTC or UTC +2 or whatever it
is the info version that's the source of
the truth so I'm not saying this
solution is better or worse than the
previous ones all I'm saying is there
are multiple approaches and using UTC is
not necessarily the best IDR is not
necessarily going to solve all your
problems and also just to wrap up there
a topic of time if you you can read some
sentences on this slide for instance
that minute has 16 60 seconds etc and
the thing about these sentences is all
of them are wrong none of this slide is
actually true so let's go through some
of the like gotchas with time so a month
begins and ends in the same year
unfortunately this only started to
happen like depending on the place you
were living in like in different
centuries for instance France started
observing new year on January 1st
in fact in 1564 but Poland or Russia
they made this decision in different
time so generally your month can start
and end in different years if you are
working with historical data February
has 28 days we obviously know this is
not true like once every four year
unless once every 100 year but once
every 400 year we get February 29th and
also Sweden when they were adopting
Gregorian calendar they thought hey like
all the countries they basically skipped
11 days because that's how many days
they had to you adjust to the Gregorian
time but Sweden was clever let's not
skip 11 days let's just introduce this
they are introducing February 29th every
4:1 blah blah blah days we'll just skip
that yeah that was a good idea only the
work came in and they forgot to do the
Sphinx so they went out of sync and one
year they decided hey let's introduce
February 40 and let's get rid of this
problem once and for all not to mention
that there are other calendars like
symmetry 454 which has 35 days in
February hopefully we are not working
with these things I mean at last 60
seconds or something like this but
definitely not hours or days unless you
are working on a virtual machine
supervised by a VM on CentOS and
have version which had this back so when
you were putting your machine to sleep
and then resuming it this clock went out
of sync so your minute could effectively
last hours so generally those are issues
we do have when we are working with time
so assuming that you would like to use
the clocks in computer science well you
need to face at least some of them but
let's say that we are working this year
not something like sixteenth century and
not in Sweden let's say that we want to
use this clock like only in few data
centers but in one timezone how can we
do that so we need to synchronize clocks
and while it may sound to you that right
there should be super brilliant clever
algorithm from doing that there is one
and it's basically hey what's the time
oh it's this time and you ask this
question multiple times one after the
other and then you try approximating
what the real time is the problem is you
ask this question over the network so
you may you may imagine there is some
latency unfortunately this latency is
not stable you may get different lags
different delays when you ask this
question and you don't know how long the
processing that time on your CPU takes
so generally we just ask this question
you get some answer and you cannot
assume anything about this answer but if
you ask this question multiple times you
may feel like yeah we're pretty sure
what the time is we should be in sync
right now obviously this in sync means
here's something like down to or up to
microseconds best probably more like
that up to milliseconds but generally we
should be in sync and there is a
protocol for that it's called NTP
Network Time Protocol it's based on the
idea of stratas so we just group the
machines in the layers each layer we
call stratum so the machines which have
access to the atomic clock there is in
so called stratum 0 they should have
like perfect clock obviously perfect to
some physical relativity etc and then
they just broadcast this time to the
machines connected to them directly to
the stratum 1 and then this follows two
different Stratos and obviously there is
some slightly more sophisticated
algorithm for NTP which is still based
on the same idea we just ask the
question hey what's the time but we try
to approximate the Layton
see the network delay the processing
time all these things but this is how we
basically synchronize time so there are
also other approaches like different
algorithms which try to be slightly more
clever one very worth mentioning is
called true time which is algorithm used
by Google in their spanner database
which basically guarentees you that you
are synchronized down to seven
milliseconds so you can actually order
events based on this time but the idea
behind this database is because I don't
know whether I am seven milliseconds
ahead or behind I just need to wait
these seven milliseconds and figure out
whether new message comes in if it does
not then I can assume my timestamp was
correct with these things etc etc but
anyway all these algorithms are based on
this flawed approach of like clocks
being not perfect so ordering events in
distributed systems based on timestamps
is not necessarily going to work so
let's see what we can use instead how to
avoid using clocks in computer science
to order their locks so once again user
comes to our system we would like to log
some information from multiple machines
from multiple nodes so then we can later
capture all these logs log entries and
order them so we know in which order
they were actually happening so what we
would like to do is we would like to
have like some working notion so that
when we have two events and B we can say
that a happened before B and we would
like to have this quarantine that a
happened before B not some approximation
we would like to do it over multiple
machines over internet so one machine is
London the other one is in Seattle and
in Tokyo we want it to be fast generally
fast so we don't want to wait like
seconds or whatever else we would like
to for it to work as fast as possible
and we are also interested in events of
only one workflow meaning that user a
comes to our system and we want to
figure out what the events for user a
were only so if user B comes to our
system at approximately the same time we
don't want to compare this even's
weather
user B was earlier or later than user a
that's behind beyond the scope what we
would like to do is only order events
for user a so what we are going to
implement is a Fink code lampert time
stamp or a Lamport happened before
relation so we say that even a
influenced even B and we denote this
with this arrow notation and what we do
is we'll be able to order events as long
as one influenced the other so this
notation or actually this theory allows
us how to calculate these things and the
idea is super simple if we are running
on one machine then we are executing
like our source code line by line if we
drop out the memory optimization and and
these things happening like city
ordering but we can assume that lines
are executed one by one so previous line
influences the next line that's the
first thing we assume but when two
machines they work together we say that
even a influence even be when there was
a communication between machines
so if machine a called machine B we can
safely say that whatever happened after
machine B received the request was after
then after sending the communication
from machine a so this is pretty
intuitive when we are going on one
machine we just go in order when we are
going in multiple machines then we
cannot tell anything as until we just
communicate between these machines and
this is the algorithm like the
specification of it but instead of going
through the textual representation
let's see some example graphical one so
what we are going to do is we will have
three machines here so we will have
machine one two and three and all these
machines they maintain separate
independent clocks clocks here we think
of like an integer value not necessarily
the time stamp so we can see that my
first machine is basically running with
let's say six seconds resolution so the
clock increases by six seconds yes
second machine increases by eight
seconds last machine increases by ten
seconds if we blindly follow timestamps
not the Lamport relation
sheep everything works fine for
communication for the message a because
it was sent here at time 6 and received
that time 16 yeah this works well this
message also sent up 24 received at 40
problems start out to appear when we go
from last machine which sent a message
at time 60 to the second machine which
received the message at time 56 so
obviously now we travel back in time and
this is not something which should work
anymore
the same goes here 64 we receive it in
54 so what happens if we introduce the
Lamport time stamps so we keep the same
clocks again only this time these two
messages are still correct because
nothing broke nothing broke here but
when we introduce when we get these
messages which potentially may introduce
problems what we do is we get the values
of clocks from two machines so here we
would get value which was previously 16
sorry 56 and here we get values sent
time which is 16 and these two machines
when they communicate they send their
clocks so machine free sends its clock
to second machine now second machine
gets its own clock which is showing 56
takes the clock of the third machine
which is showing 16 then it calculates
the maximum of two values and
incremented by one so does the algorithm
so now machine first and sixty and
second machine is now updating its own
clock and getting the maximum of value
incrementing it so we can see that the
next time stamp on this machine because
this machine was going like in with the
8 milli
8 seconds resolution is also 8 seconds
apart from 61 to 69 the same thing is
actually happening here yes so we are
sending at 69 receiving at previously it
was 54 now we get maximum of these two
value we incremented we have value 70
here okay that's the idea of Lamport
time stamps and now what happens with
this influential with this that even a
influenced even be so when it comes to
one machine we can say that each event
influences the next one so we can
clearly
we are executing in order they influence
each other but when it comes to these
events for instance even 12 and 18 we
cannot tell anything about this event
for even 0 & 8 as long as we don't
communicate but once we do communicate
once we do have this communication here
we can say that all these events
influenced all these events here because
there was a communication so we know
they get in sync at some point and we
can compare these events pretty simple
idea but once we introduced it what we
get is a very strong statement then once
we know that even a happened before B
and influenced B so a influenced B we
know that clock a is less than clogged B
so when we know there was some
communication between machines then we
can just compare their clocks and figure
out which events were like happened
before also unfortunately we cannot tell
that about all the events so if we go
back to the example here we cannot for
instance tell weather events 36 on
machine first happened before event 48
even 40 here that we don't know because
there was there were some other events
between communication which happened
only here so we don't know that these
events influenced each other we probably
even see that they did not so we cannot
tell which of them actually happened
earlier so that we cannot tell but once
we they do communicate we can just
compare the clocks so how do you
implement this in like distributed
system in real-life implementation so
we'll go through some very simple dotnet
implementation but the idea should be
generally you can transfer it to any
language or framework of your choice
once you just understand how it's
supposed to work so what we are going to
do is we need to carry on two pieces of
information first piece is the
correlation ID so user comes to our
system we need to generate some unique
identifier showing hey this is the
workflow of the user this is the
transaction we start so it's generated
only once it's unique and it's also
propagated across the system then
logical time is maintained
just as we've seen on the previous slide
so each node is having its own time and
when we do communicate we need to pass
the time and we need to update the time
and carry it on so what we start with is
we introduce some interface code I
correlator which basically gives us the
access to these two those two pieces of
information yes to correlation ID and to
logical time to this lamp or timestamp
it also has a method to update logical
time which we use when we do communicate
and we can also introduce something like
human readable activity telling us what
is actually happening this will be
helpful for our log information so we
start with this correlator
and what we are doing here is we
basically need to implement this lamp or
timestamp right now so whenever we do
get the logical time we just increment
it by 1 because hey some event
influenced other event so we just
increment it this is when we are just
getting to the time within one machine
ok and we use interlocked increment just
to avoid unnecessarily locking some like
monitors or these things but when we do
communicate what we are trying to do
right now is we get this new time from
some other system and what we do is we
just calculate the final time which is
now the maximum of these two times and
again we do the interlocked compare
exchange just to store the new value of
the time yes so this is how we store
these things and this is the basic
implementation you can see that this
class is still abstract because we will
now be we need to fill in the second
piece of information which is
correlation ID but this implementation
we want to use across all the nodes all
the machines in our distributed system
so what do we do next is we would like
to have some logging infrastructure so
we do have a logger interface with
logging level etc and message you do
have some correlator here and you just
implement it in some in some way so
whenever you do log your message you
basically have the following segments
and I'm not saying these segments are
sufficient or decent for this pieces of
information are all you need to to debug
your application but they generally are
a good start so we do have some human
readable timestamp like hey it was 2
p.m. London time application name so you
know where this is coming from you
have some instanceid of your machine
thread either managed thread or Windows
Fred ID whatever else correlation ID
obviously because we need to know for
which workflow this message was logged
level 4 in 4 or whatever activity so
it's easier to read and teleological
time so the lamp or time stop logger ID
if you have multiple loggers in your
framers can also be useful and obviously
at the very end we does need to law so
log the message for the system yeah so
we do have again some abstract class
giving us this ass this very nice log
method which does the trick and from now
on we just need to fill in all the
missing parts so we imagine that we
consider this simple example so user
comes to our distributed system what we
need to do initially is we need to
generate this correlation ID and
initialize a logical time on the machine
we are heating with this can be your
load balancer webserver whatever else
yes so you just create correlation ideas
go in you go it or whatever else
whatever you'd like and you just store
it in your memory base correlator here
so you can see that it inherits from the
correlator so now correlate or the base
class provides the implementation of
this lamp or timestamp here we introduce
correlation ID so this is when we start
the workflow now because we are in
distributed system we need to start
communicating with some other nodes
databases like file storage whatever
else what we need to do right now we
need to pass all the information to the
node we are communicating with so we can
for instance implement like our own rest
client and pass these things using color
using HTTP headers yes so we ought to
know two more headers and correlation ID
correlation counter so like logical
timestamp and we just extract them and
pass them later on ok so this is what we
are calling some remote node within our
system what we do next is we get HTTP
request
we just need to parse these things so
depending on the framework of your
choice you may have some like action
filters or action handlers or whatever
else like based constructor of your of
your activities what all we need to do
is we just need to get the request from
from HTTP context so to get correlation
encounter and also get the correlation
ID yeah so we just get the request we
parse this data and we initialize our
request headers correlator so this thing
also inherits from correlator is using
exactly the same implementation only the
way we initialize these things is
slightly different what we do next is we
need to reply back to the service which
called us so what we need to do is once
again we need to pass the new time
because we finish the communication so
what we do now is we just get the like
the same rest client which we had before
but now when the action is executed like
when we finished getting the oh sorry
that was one step ahead let's go back we
need to return their headers so we need
to once again wire them up in returning
the response of our server so this is
action filter or an action executed or
whatever else you do have in your
framework so the same way we previously
were parsing headers which were given to
us now we are just adding them as a
response yes so we add these two headers
that read that was correlation ID
probably we don't need to return the
correlation ID but it's good to have it
in case we are like examining the
network traffic and also we do have the
time and on the other side right now we
need to update the headers when the
request we send comes back with the
answer so we get to the to the rest
client again and previously we were
adding headers here now we just get the
response so we parse the headers and
extract this data okay so this is how we
need to do it or how one of the possible
implementations for these things and
there are few more few important remarks
when we are implementing it in this way
so generally we would like to make our
life easier we probably would like to
wire this up for some dependency
injection etc so it's always injected
into all the places we have important
thing here is I only covered the HTTP
rest communication if you are using some
an service bus as MSM queue or whatever
queues are there file storage etc you
always need to somehow wire up this
metadata yes this information so whether
you add them as like metadata to the
message post pushed onto the service bus
or the file name whatever else you just
need to propagate
somehow now you need to log this
something so this ilogger which i
present it to you you probably would
like to use it with some log4net or n
log or whatever library of your choice
whether you put it on top of the library
or below the libraries like a matter of
taste and finally what happens now we
started with this question hey user
comes to our system something went wrong
now the user needs to figure out or asks
us hey go and figure out what happened
so what we need to do right now is we
just show the user okay this is your ID
when you reach out to us please give us
this string so this is the correlation
ID user comes to our support and tells
us hey you wanted me to give you this
string back we just grab this string we
go to our log stash Cabana or AMS
whatever else we have and then we just
filter out logs based on correlation ID
order them based on the alum port
timestamp and as long as we do know
what's going on in the system because we
need to keep in mind that which events
influence which others we can just order
them and go through them one by one so
this is the idea how to sort these
things and how to make the logs much
clearer okay but that's just the
beginning what we were considering until
now is there is one user coming to our
system and it's he starts a workflow but
if there was another user and she was
starting another workflow we assumed we
don't want to compare these things now
the question is can we somehow extend
this system to be able to compare all
the events in it so we can safely say or
easily say that hey this event happened
before that event and that event can be
any event in our system because as long
as we do not want to do this we can go
with simple Lamport implementation and
it works for like one constraint
workflow but once we want to compare
everything with everything it's getting
harder so we won't solve this problem in
its entirety because this is actually a
lot of computer science research what
I'm going to show you is how these
problems are tackled and what components
we need to have to solve all of them so
first thing we would like
to introduce is a concept of vector
clocks so previously we had a logical
clock each machine had one value its own
independent clock right what we are
doing right now is each machine is going
to have a vector of clocks representing
the state of the clocks of every other
notes so what we do now instead of
seeing the text representation let's see
it here we just introduce the clocks
once the like on the go so each machine
starts with just one clock its own clock
but then once they communicate they pass
the clocks and then once again implement
this logic for getting maximum of the
clocks and incrementing them yes so you
can see that seek here communicates to
two with the machine B and it passes its
own clock with value 1
so then machine B gets their values and
from now on it stores two clocks for B
and C then when it communicates with a
it passes these clocks etc etc so we
just communicate we exchange all the
clock values so in theory we should know
what's the time on every other machine
now what this gives us is previously our
clock was just one integer now our
vector clock is basically a vector so we
have multiple values of there and then
we introduce this comparison relation
again so this time we say that vector
clock of a is less than vector clock of
B if for each components vector clock of
like this component matching components
is not greater and there is at least one
component which is strictly less than
the matching component of the other
vector once we do have this this match
this relation we can say that if we know
that vector clock of a is less than
vector clock of B we know that a
happened before B this is something we
didn't have before previously we did
know that if a influenced B then their
clocks were one of was strictly less
than the other but now we can just
compare the clocks and as long as they
are in this relation then we can tell
which event happened before the other
one okay obviously by definition of
relation you can say that not all the
events will be comparable yes because it
may happen that one component is
strictly greater the other component is
strictly lower yes so it is not
necessarily is not sufficient to compare
all the events but once we have this
relation it's a step forward how to do
it and there are some other
generalizations of these clocks
obviously so they are slightly more
efficient when it comes to like how many
clocks we store so make this vector
smaller etc but generally they are all
based on the same idea what we do next
is we need to introduce our understand
what we are exactly dealing with so we
introduce a concept of Byzantine
generals and there is a name of or this
means an effect which our when our
machines they start behaving weirdly so
a short story
imagine that all these generals so there
is one general multiple lieutenants
there is an army which basically wants
to attack some city yes so general makes
a decision hey we are going to attack
now and general is sending this
information to all the lieutenant's but
then one of the lieutenant's is
malicious he wants us to lose so he
starts lying to others and says hey the
general told us to retreat so we can
clearly see that once we have a
lieutenant like this malicious
lieutenant things may go pretty bad
because if general cannot reach out some
other lieutenant then the malicious
lieutenant may pass incorrect
information to that one so we may get
out of sync and get like split brain in
this situation and now how the how does
this apply to computer science and here
we can imagine that each of people here
is basically a separate machine and the
attack or retreat order is basically a
network communication now if a machine
has this so-called Byzantine fault it
means that it goes and behaves
completely unpredictably we would like
it so when the machine fails we would
like it to probably remain quiet or just
die and never come back
however in reality it's not the case
because it in reality
in distributed systems all the
components can fail but the failure may
be of different types the failure may be
that the node just dies and never
returns it may be that it starts
violating the protocol sending the
messages whether it's not supposed to be
sending them it may be that it's
repeating the messages or it may be
sending out broken messages broken
messages here is basically saying this
retreat instead of attack okay
so once we get to this situation when we
cannot trust any of our components how
do we actually figure out what's the
order of things in our operating zone in
our distributed system and this is not a
question of if something goes wrong this
is a question of when these things
happen because in distributed systems
everything is going to fail sooner or
later so what we are going to do right
now before we get to ordering events is
we would like to figure out how do we
get one value assuming it was replicated
across multiple nodes so there is some
in fostering the database we would like
to read this info yes and what is going
on we say that system is careful
tolerant when it can survive failure of
K nodes at most K nodes so now the
question is how many nodes do we need to
be able to extract this piece of
information when K systems can go down
the answer is in that super simple
situation when we don't have Byzantine
failures it's K plus 1
why we just ask every single of k plus 1
systems and one of them must be working
properly because only K are allowed to
die yes or we assume only K will die so
in that case it works but if we do have
Byzantine failures then it's not
sufficient to get k plus 1 answers or
escape like what k plus 1 systems
because the nodes may lie to us they may
give us incorrect answers hey was the
value of this variable and is basically
lying what we need to do is we need to
do the majority voting so we ask 2 k
plus 1 systems k of them are lying we
get answers
from other k plus one which is correct
and because of majority voting we can
safely deduce that hey this was the
correct value so this is when it's come
to reading but how do we modify this
value imagine now two users come to your
system user a is in London user base in
Tokyo they want to buy the last piece of
something and you need to decide which
of them was actually the first one to
ask for that item so now we need to
solve the so-called consensus problem so
we need to agree on some decision and to
agree on that we would like to have nice
protocol which basically stuff like
fulfills these properties which are like
mathematical ideas but basically this
should be pretty robust in pretty stable
yes so when we Dave the machines finally
agree on something they agree on the
same value and this value was proposed
by at least one machine yes that's the
idea
we obviously specified that there is a
termination so there is a finite number
of steps so it's not going like forever
and the integrity and all the other
things so this is the problem we are now
trying to solve so we are we're capable
of reading something now we are
modifying something so if we assume that
we do have K fault-tolerant system so K
components die we need actually free k
plus 1 nodes in our system now to solve
this problem why is that that's because
we need to not only agree on something
but we also need to convince others how
we are going to do it the problem is we
implicitly assumed something about the
communication under the hood so we
assume that the communication basically
does not disappear it may be bounded or
bounded there are some timeouts and we
focus on mathematical like analysis of
this we can prove that for instance the
first rectangle here is if we have
synchronous unordered communication
unicast and bounded delay consensus is
not possible
when only one machine out of the
district I plus one die if one machine
dies we are not able to achieve the
consensus and it's proven that only in
this situations here marked in green yes
it's possible to get the consensus to
agree on something
and there are generally a lot of
different algorithms there are like
pretty big research and white papers
telling us how to do it efficiently how
to minimize the number of messages why
it's not possible and it's proven it's
not possible so it's not something we
suspect so generally there is a big math
behind of these things and just to give
you idea how this thing works there is
the multiple protocols one of them of
the protocols for achieving consensus is
called raft and in this protocol
basically we do have a big state machine
for each of the nodes in our system and
each node can be in one of the multiple
states and now it seems pretty easy but
proving that this state diagram and
these transitions are sufficient to
achieve the consensus it's actually
quite a lot of maths behind it so
generally each node can be in like one
of the multiple states and general
assumption is there isn't like a leader
at some point and the leader is pinging
all the others one the leader dies the
followers so the nodes which are
receiving this pink message they noticed
that the leader died because the pink
did not return or something like this so
now followers need to decide who is the
new leader
so each follower says hey I'm the new
leader do you all agree other nodes may
say yeah I agree or no I do not disagree
they passed some messages integers etc
etc and finally they did use who the
leader is so it seems simple there are
no multiple issues with this approach
because first if leader is unreachable
pretty often so if the leader changes it
may be that we are actually capable of
determining who the leader is but it
takes so much time that our performance
basically decreases too much it also may
be that the leader is decided just for
one decision and then the leader
election starts to happen again so we
basically spent a lot of time to decide
okay who the leader is then the leader
decides on one thing and then it dies
out or whatever else and we need to
decide again so there are multiple
issues with this approaches but once we
do have this consensus we can implement
this again mathematical proofs that we
can implement these operations here in
the
tributed system so for instance we can
do the total ordered broadcast which is
basically a communication that I sent a
message to all the nodes in my system
and I have AG warranty that this message
happened before other messages or after
other messages and that all the working
nodes which are still working correctly
they do receive this message properly
and they acknowledge it and they
commented etc we can also implement
distributed compare and set we can also
implement distributed increment and get
so we can finally agree on the order of
events and once we can do that like
solving the issue we had with logs is
now super simple because in theory we
can just communicate each other and say
hey I'm logging this now okay they
decide who the leader is they elect they
store it obviously we're not doing it
this way because it gives the
performance but we can agree on things
like hey two users are trying to buy
this one item who wins this this this
idea obviously now there are other
questions like whether we want this
consistency maybe we would like to have
eventual consistency well then we don't
need this distributed transactions at
all but this is like a story on its own
and just to give you an idea how these
things are hard there is a project
called Jepsen Jepsen is supposed to
evaluate distributed systems and show
that they are working or they are not
working correctly so the owners of for
instance MongoDB and other distributed
databases they reach out to Jepsen
people and they try to evaluate whether
this work correctly so once you get to
to your database tutorial or
documentation and it tells you that hey
we have this strong consistency
guarentees of all the things it's easy
like if you do have proved that proving
it by jep's and then you probably can
safely assume it's working as expected
and Jepsen already showed that multiple
databases were losing data pretty often
were not honoring the consistency they
were guaranteeing etc so take a look at
this Google some YouTube videos about
Jepsen how they were proving things
summary wall clock as we've seen is
pretty tricky and it's not usable in
distributed systems
Lamport time stamp is a way to do it
if we do have sufficiently simple
situation if we do have harder
situations then we probably need to use
some well-built
distributed systems which are also
evaluated correctly and basically
guaranteed to work properly and all
these things we you can you always need
to assume that hey these things will go
wrong
your machines will die your machines
will fail and you do have Byzantine
failures so those things will not work
correctly okay having said that it's
time for QA any questions this is the QR
code pointing to the slide deck by the
way so if you'd like to download it
there is a way to go questions here okay
I don't see any questions feel free to
reach out to me offline or after this
talk during the conference before we
will just wait a few seconds for people
to scan this QR code and then we will
just wrap up with some resources
references so if you would like to read
more about distributed systems you are
now interested in this time stamps
vector clocks all these things around
there are some books I think I can
recommend for you so you can start with
ton and bound distributed systems
principles and paradigms that's pretty
nice introduction and also designing
data intensive application is a pretty
good one telling you how to implement
these things working in a distributed
fashion and giving you our very good
performance yeah there are some other
books as well feel free to take a look
at them also if you would like to read
things on the internet some links for
you to read about lab for time stamps or
all the funny stories about like Sweden
February 30 and all these things so
falsehood' better programmers believe
about time logging in distributed system
implementation this is basically my blog
post serious with this implementation so
you can get the slide deck from there or
get the code which which is supposed to
be working correctly and having said all
of that I'd like to thank you for
attending this talk my name is Adam for
monoghan I hope you enjoyed it thank you
you